this is how you make chicken tinola this  is the dish my mom makes whenever she  doesn't feel like cooking because it's  so easy shout out to moms now I'm using  legs and thighs season with salt  and black pepper okay now medium heat  add some oil sear the chicken  in the same pot add your Ginger  add your onions  add the chicken back  and a chicken stock Cube okay now we're  gonna bring it up to a boil and once it  boils we're going to lower the heat to a  simmer until the chicken is completely  cooked okay after 40 minutes add your  sayote this is chayote or sayote you  should be able to find us at any Asian  stores you can also use green papaya or  you don't even have to put this in a  dish up to you and add your spinach  finish it with some fish sauce